hey everybody it's Mike from motorflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about Delta
weakness you know
um Delta is you know one for me one of
the cornerstones of order flow right
Delta is the difference between net
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in a bar and you know every once in a
while someone will post a comment under
one of my videos about uh Delta uh you
know is useless Delta doesn't matter
anymore and you know I joked that I get
triggered by it honestly I don't get
triggered by it you know I do know that
everyone has their opinion on how they
approach the market how they trade the
market and what they look at right being
an order flow Trader I think uh you know
things like Delta is are very important
you know the people that are commenting
on that you know they got their own way
and God bless them if it's successful
for them then you know so be it
um you know it's one of those things
where you know in trading trading is a
journey you don't really get to that
Final Destination
Okay so
let's go ahead and get started with uh
today's topic of
Delta weakness okay now
when you think of the term weakness
right you think of something getting you
know weaker like a move ending or
something but in in the sense when I
when I talk about Delta weakness
um you know really what I'm talking
about is there's a weakening in the
Delta
um from strong to kind of like neutral
and
really quick on our software
I'm going to show you you know how to
see it if you're not using the software
on our software we have it right uh here
we call it Market weakness okay and you
know you could have a a certain link
that you want to look at right it's
going to be colored blue violet or dark
orange so you can see right here right
this is
um the Delta weakness in the sense that
the aggressive selling is getting weaker
right what it's looking for is
Delta basically decreasing over time and
you can see it you know quite clearly
here minus 609 minus 310 minus 26 okay
so
the Delta by itself it you know One bars
Delta
in a vacuum doesn't have much meaning
sometimes I mean there are times that it
does but in general
um you know the Market's going to do
what the Market's going to do which is
facilitate trade but when you have it
just over a sustained period of time in
this case three bars where you have
strong negative Delta 609 weaker 310
still negative but then minus 26 right
that where is that aggressive selling
it's it's being
I'll say it's being removed but it's
drying up right and that often is a sign
of a potential Market reversal and you
can see here right we got this little
pop-up here right right now it's you
know three in the afternoon here you
just closed on Friday but same thing
here right Market is going up right this
is the bearish market weakness in the
sense that you have aggressive buying
right we just took out the swing high
and you know maybe potentially going to
go higher
you see the Deltas you know 976 strong
811 894 516 only 189 up here then even
within this bar if you're analyzing the
Delta you can see it went from positive
189 I'm sorry it went from Max Delta 711
and it just finished at 189. so on this
way up
even though we're going higher price is
going higher you have aggressive buyers
in there but the aggressive buying is is
weakening right so if that aggressive
buying on a move up is weakening who's
going to take the market higher once
those aggressive buyers which is causing
the positive Delta
are done buying
no one
the aggressive selling disorder takes
over from there and you can see the
market sell off
um you know here I can see this purple
line let's go take a look at it there's
there's a few these came from earlier
right you went up it pulled back on your
pullback that aggressive selling was
getting a little bit weaker down down
again you know we had been going up here
we pulled back it's getting weaker
the selling is getting weaker those are
those nice pullbacks that you want to
buy
okay here is
some aggressive buying that weekend and
then it took off again so this one
failed
but down here right you got one here one
here okay so yeah this one failed again
not always does it immediately end
but again if you know how to trade right
using risk management using you know
stops in the market yeah okay you take
your stop you get stopped out here
it's got a nice trade right here the
next one is a beautiful one right from
you know the 25-ish area all the way up
to 35. it's a nice 10 point move
right here's a nice bearish one right we
sold off pulled back put on this
pullback that aggressive buying right
because anytime you pull back
you could just keep going higher but if
that if you can identify that this
aggressive buying on this pullback has
weakened
and it's basically being shut off what
do you think is going to happen you can
position yourself to take a nice low
risk trade you know getting short right
you know after this bar is closing and
you know we start to trade down a little
bit getting short here at 32 a stop just
above this high
the audit goes down a quick 10 points
down to 22. right there's you know
there's more levels in here I want to
find those you know here's well that one
was generated on a number so I'm not
sure I'd be willing to take it you know
anytime a big number comes out I'd say
it was non-parent payrolls
um yeah be careful now
this is an eight range chart okay and
I've talked about choosing your tart
chart type to suit your trading style if
I were to go to a minute phase chart
right this is a a one minute chart
you know today same day and I don't
think there was you know there was one
signal here there's a bearish signals
open that up a little bit right you got
this little pullback and it sold off
you know 15 down to the 13 12 and a half
I think that was about it right I mean
there's one here there's a small one
potentially here but
the next bar didn't even go lower so I
wouldn't even consider that one um I
like the market to start moving lower if
I get the signal if I get a short signal
or moving higher if I get a Buy Signal
it was a buy down here as you're sort of
going sideways
but on the one minute chart right you
don't see any signals on the eight range
chart you see a bunch of signals now
if you go to
this is uh what is this your currency
right this is an eight range chart okay
unless you know I see one Buy Signal
here you know one up here I'm not
looking to get long up here there's a
potential short here it's on the one
minute chart
not sorry that's on the eight range
chart
but if I look on the one minute chart
same markets just different type chart
type I mean it was a short here
short there are some nice shorts up here
here
yeah so it's going to vary basically on
on the chart that you're looking at
um you know what do we got here this is
a 10 year right 10 years today I like
looking at 10 years on on range-based
charts
right up here
high of the day sell off
weakness coming in here go sideways sell
off a little bit pull back more Market
weakness coming in here
this was uh this purple level again that
was during the number I again I'm always
kind of hesitant on signals generated
around a number today was non-farm
payrolls but you know that's the whole
concept of you know Market weakness
right anytime you're up near a high or a
low or you get some sort of pullback you
know down here this was the previous day
you know you can't come you're pulling
back down into the low of the day right
you're selling off right this was the
high you're selling off selling off down
into here
and then what happened Market went back
up to the highs Okay so
again
depending on the market that you're
trading the chart type you're trading
you may see more you may see less I said
you know today on the e-minis on the on
the one minute chart there wasn't much
but on the
eight range chart you know there was
quite a few you know the day before just
curious you know day before on the one
minute chart you know there's a nice one
that happened around 7 56
um you know from about 33 down into the
20s right before the cash opened and
sort of rallied back up to those levels
and sold off again
right so
again you know choosing your chart type
is important
sometimes you're going to get more
signals on certain features of the order
flow sometimes you're going to get less
signals it really comes down to what you
want to see on your chart again not
everybody uses the market weakness so if
you maybe you're using a minute based
chart you don't use it it doesn't matter
to you but if you're on a range based
chart it's it's definitely something I
think you know you you should look into
and throw it up on your chart again we
got all these tools
in here
exhaustion prints
imbalance reversal inverse rebalance
Market sweeps Market weakness detector
right here now you could even if you
want you could even shorten it to two
I wouldn't I think three is about just
nice if you get if you go down to two
obviously it's going to generate more
signals so the lower you go on on the
amount
um the more signals you're going to get
right you're seeing here here
you don't there's no point in having
more signals if you're going to be over
trading taking a lot more trades that
you probably
don't need to take all right but again
you know sometimes people say well I
could take the extra trades like this if
I could catch a trade like this
okay
so again at the end of the day it's up
to you if like I said you can even go
further all right let's go in here
and set it to four
which is quite strong
and let's see if there's even any
signals that come up with four
last couple of days here
really this is the night session
yeah I don't want to see anything
so you know on a one minute e-mini chart
four is probably too strong curious how
it would look on an eight range chart
let's take a look here
SEC here
oh you still got that one I think that
was generated during the
change the number here so you see right
this is today
okay here this was done at one in the
morning okay that was a nice one one
from the low of the day literally quite
literally the low of the day it tells
you how quiet the session was you know
we're coming into the European open and
we had a high of 22 and three quarters a
low of 13 and a half
but it's giving you this nice signal and
here you actually got a lot of things
going on in the order flow you've got
imbalance reversal bullish Power Point
control Market weakness you know in the
market you know had a nice move up
but again there's not a whole going to a
setting of four even on an eight range
chart you're not getting a lot of
signals so about three is about the max
I I use I don't use two I think two is
too uh too short so three is uh just
nice all right everybody I hope you guys
got something out of this video and you
understand Delta weakness works and what
to look for in it so I'll see you guys
on the next video bye-bye